this is unbelievably gorgeous  Oh mine better get it out one last time  you know before I'm just too over the  hill it's the color of this dress is  just make it sick do you feel fabulous I  think so I don't know this is it yeah  thank you I'm gonna rub that off onto me  so okay Golden Globes fabulous here we  are the politician from here for the  politician the show husband and the show  of course yeah he's a great Nike I do I  think it's it's actually pretty fun and  relaxed compared to a lot of the awards  I like it too  I always I mean Ricky Gervais is usually  takes it to the next level of irreverent  so I'm excited to see what happens  [Laughter]  [Music]  it should be fine though it will be fun  that's the whole thing about tonight and  fabulous people yeah really amazing  talents you know it's always inspiring  to be around people who made such  beautiful work  [Music]